our 8 news now investigators with new
text messages between two fake electors
from Nevada now under federal
investigation Friday marks two years
since the January 6 Capital Riot today 8
news now investigator David Charles
shows us the evidence the January 6
Committee just released
urgent Trump Pence campaign asked me to
contact you to coordinate December 14th
voting by Nevada electors that's the
email Nevada Republican party National
committeeman Jim degraffenreed received
two days before he and five others
signed these fake electoral certificates
as the eight news now investigators
first reported the signed documents were
sent to Washington through the postal
service from the Northern Nevada town of
Minden evidence the January 6 committee
released includes text messages between
degraph and read and another fake
elector Sean Meehan talking about
Congress meeting to certify the election
Meehan said this makes me wonder if a
patriot out there aware of the theft
might take a second amendment approach
to solving the problem to be clear for
the NSA technicians reading this text I
do not want nor am I advocating for
violence with no court finding evidence
of fraud degraffen Reed texted this on
December 28th the entire situation sucks
we see very clearly what is being done
yet at every turn we are blockaded from
putting the facts out in public the
Nevada Secretary of State's office the
state supreme court and several judges
reviewed the documents finding no
evidence of fraud the Nevada GOP also
repeatedly refused to show their
evidence when we asked on January 7th a
day after rioter stormed the capital and
Congress certified the results for
President Joe Biden degraffen Reed
texted this I don't think we yet know
all of the ramifications for what Trump
and a small number of expletive
supporters of his did to us yesterday
while the work of the January 6
committee is now complete the Department
of Justice is continuing its
investigation into the fake elector
scheme to grafen read and Meehan did not
return comments for requests today
Nevada GOP chair Michael McDonald nor
the party itself have responded to
requests for comments on this issue